So, to summarize what we can say about function behavior, or at least this
aspect of it. If the value of the function goes down as the value of x goes up,
then we say that the function is decreasing. Just like over here where it's
sloping down. Now if instead f of x increases as x increases, then we say that
the function is increasing. Like in this part of the graph. The third option is
that f of x doesn't change at all as x increases. Here, f of x is a constant. So
here I've drawn another sort of silly looking graph, and I'm going to divide it
into several regions. So for each of the regions of the domain that I've split
up right here on the left, I'd like you to tell me if in that range in the
domain, the function, which is g of x in this case, is increasing, decreasing,
or a constant? Please pick one of these 3 values for each part of the domain.